Traduttore: Dalila Neri
Revisore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
Mio padre amava le donne.
Tutte! Indistintamente!
Diceva che le donne sono farfalle
In testa posseggono una polverina
che le fa volare,
ma se un uomo gliela ruba,
rimangono a terra, divengono concime.
Papà! Anche la mamma è una farfalla?
No, tua madre è sempre stata una rana.
L'aveva conosciuta quando ancora
una parte della terra,
di proprietà del nostro padrone,
non era stata bonificata.
C'erano nuvole di zanzare e grosse rane
che si gonfiavano come mongolfiere.
Le rane non cantano,
sono monotone, le rane,
e ripetitive.
Proprio come mia madre.
Conosceva, infatti, solo poche parole.
E il suo corpo aveva la grazia
dell'acqua stagnante,
che non si muove.
Numerosi parti le avevano lasciato
la pancia rigonfia,
le gambe leggermente
divaricate all'infuori.
La sua pelle era stata sempre opaca.
Non fu mai un'amante per mio padre,
ma solo una madre compagna.
Non ricordo tra loro gesti d'affetto.
So, però, che lui l'amava e l'adorava,
e la rispettava come la Madonna
Lo so perché non l'ha mai picchiata,
anche quando tornava ubriaco dall'osteria.
Eccitato.
Con due gote rosse sulla faccia,
e le goccioline di sudore
che brillavano sul collo
per i giochi fantasiosi delle sue amiche.
Non c'era un dialogo
tra mio padre e mia madre.
Non era necessario.
Erano abituati al silenzio, e ai vuoti.
Non solo di parole.
Era una brava donna tua madre e,
se la povertà non le avesse rubato
il desiderio e il pensiero,
sarebbe stata una moglie ideale.
Ma mia madre,
mia madre era diversa da lui.
Era devota solo al dovere,
per lei la vita era sacrificio.
Non provava gioia nel vivere,
ma rassegnazione.
Ma credo che proprio a lei
pensava mio padre
ogni volta che raccontava
la storia di una donna.
Pensava a lei, alla sua sottomissione,
alla sua incapacità di sognare.
Ma pensava a lei.
Le donne della mia terra profumano
come le rose di San Giovanni.
E sembrano anfore con i pugni
poggiati sopra i fianchi,
custodi di liquidi ancestrali.
Il loro ritmo é quello lunare.
Sacerdotesse di credi antichi
dove i figli sono l'unica ricchezza
e i vecchi rappresentano
la saggezza dei popoli.
Non si sa come facciano l'amore
perché non ostentano la sensualità,
né la danno a vedere.
Ma l'ondeggiare dei lunghi capelli neri
e il calpestio dei piedi scalzi
sul pavimento delle case
promettono melodie da sirene.
Infatti cantano mentre sfaccendano,
cantano sempre.
Sono terra e mare, le mie donne.
Sono le mie figlie.
Mia madre, la mia donna,
sono tutte le donne del sud
che ancora cantano, e cantano e
non si stancheranno mai
di cantare.
(Applausi)